it's time for cruise news the good news
stefan and your big old news bird and
with me at the desk if he were a turkey
he'd have an amazing tail feather oh
yeah
[Applause]
it's almost thanksgiving oh my gosh well
you know what that means ross i do know
what that means it's the macy's
thanksgiving day
it's going to parade
to the public this year
and crowds are going to get a new
balloon space.com reports a funko pop
inspired grogu balloon which will be
making its way down 6th avenue that's
right you know what this is all code for
what baby yoda
from the mandalorian
is joining the balloon crew this big
baby is 41 feet tall
ross i need to know
the bts of what it's really like to be
at the macy's day parade especially in
the pandemic uh-huh didn't you do it
last year yeah i've covered the macy's
day parade uh a bunch of times there i
am that's when real world was normal
life right that's like that's glory days
yes and this was last year when it was
just empty streets except for people
holding balloons let me tell you
something there isn't whether it's a
pandemic or not there is nothing like
the thanksgiving day parade here in new
york city it is you feel incredible
but we're back and it's back it's back
to normal-ish you know and the streets
are going to be filled with people i
need this thanksgiving don't you i i am
very looking forward to it i'm spending
it with uh the whole family and i'm so
excited you know will my kid's dad he
used to go to the thanksgiving day
parade when he was a kid
and i just think it's it is it's really
beautiful to return to some
semblance of normalcy and may we never
not appreciate it you know what i'm
going to set a goal right here right now
maybe next year you and i will be on a
float
could it be a stuffing float oh girl she
drew barrymore and stuffing she just
won't let off antoinette and gloria
how's it going over there
i've got stuffing on the bridge i know
you have stuffing on the brain well this
thanksgiving a lot of couples are going
to be eating stuffing but they're also
going to be meeting the parents but the
question is is your relationship ready
for it interesting refinery 29 share
tips from relationship experts about
bringing your boyfriend or girlfriend to
the family for the first time before you
go you should help your partner with
some inside scoop like hey you should
say by the way mom loves it when people
do the dishes without asking okay so do
the dishes or you could say oh um uncle
rob is going to offend you in like 25
different ways and we've ignored him
since 1988 and he should be canceled
immediately you should give that tip out
there also they say introduce your
partner to a few family members
beforehand so when they're there it's
not just them against everyone else they
have like you know
cousin joe's like on their side you know
or just bring lots and lots of wine
because i find
that
sometimes uptight aunt helen just needs
to toss a few back and then she's a
whole lot of fun you know what i mean oh
they don't call it an icebreaker for
nothing thank you um i i love the tip
about maybe meeting a few family members
beforehand so that you have the oh hey
and you can kind of pick up where you
left off you know that that's a very
good idea it is a real icebreaker what
are you and welly doing for thanksgiving
uh we're going to be making stuffing i'm
going to be cooking
i'll be in palm springs so it'll be like
80 degrees i'll be in the pool
i'll probably be at the bottom of the
pool because i had so much stuffing i'll
just
how much stuffing could you eat i want
someone to pretend i am the thanksgiving
turkey and just stuff me with
the stuffing that's what i want this way
get it in there that is such a visual
okay
it's what i want okay
we don't judge well it's not even
thanksgiving yet but some people are
actually
getting ready for christmas at the
stroke of midnight on november 1st
mariah carey queen of christmas did a
full-on pumpkin smash to ring in the new
season
she was the queen of christmas yeah
and the son reports one christmas
um one christmas uh prepper named kate
hall has already prepared her family's
entire christmas dinner this is
interesting this really caught my eye
because over two days in september she
prep potatoes carrots parsnip sprouts
even her gravy she put it all in
ziplocks labeled them with a marker
tossed them into the jumbo freezer and
said sand december feast
thoughts i don't like it at all okay i
don't
because i think part of the fun of
christmas is the panic that it's all
gonna fall apart right
family showing up you're just the oven's
not even on yet you're freaking out no
even santa claus and elves are like girl
calm down like don't plan this much
ahead of time
if they said they freeze the stuffing i
would not be happy about that and well
you can't freeze the stuff exactly we're
debating the hardcore stuff here today
and we've got another holiday debate
here's the question is it okay to bring
your leftover containers
to holiday dinners at somebody else's
house i have i feel very strongly about
something here i i i think please bring
your to-go containers to my house
because i am more offended
by you taking my to-go containers
and never giving
they say they say oh i'll wash it and
return it
i haven't seen you for a year
where is it
you know who you are
all right well today we're going to
break it down with point counterpoint
and we've got two audience members who
strongly disagree on this issue let's
start it up with a yes to tupperware
coming from kimberly mitchell kimberly
so you think
people should bring their own tupperware
to holiday parties it's perfectly fine
to bring your tupperware thanksgiving
because first of all i just want to say
i love thanksgiving so much it's my
absolute favorite holiday because it's
all about the food yeah
and let's be honest a lot of that is the
leftovers i mean who doesn't love a
turkey cranberry sandwich yeah thank you
so much for bringing that up that's
beautiful yes i think you know
do you know what i'm thinking about as i
eat thanksgiving dinner i'm thinking
about eating thanksgiving dinner number
two
right exactly the leftovers exactly
um all right well from the other side a
big no is richard tucker richard richard
hello richard hello
[Applause]
why yeah sorry go ahead why are you a no
if you did not create that meal you
should not expect to take anything home
you show up you say happy thanksgiving
it's so good to see you and then when
there's extra food you take it in the
ziploc bag in the tin foil you don't
bring out the tupperware
it's a little trashy wait a minute are
you saying
are you saying yeah you
love you
send me home with a ziploc am i an
animal you're wrong and i'm fine with it
[Applause]
[Music]